I've got a story for you that stretches
over 700 years and the best way to start
it is with a 16th century joke Amandla
dried to the market with two bushels of
wheat but because his horse shouldn't
carry a heavy load he carried the wheat
on his own neck but still rode the horse
I'm not saying it's a great 16th century
joke but that is one of the merry tales
of the Mad Men of Gautam a 16th century
compilation of stories insulting the
intelligence of the people of this town
which is pronounced Gautam the jokes
compiled in that book date back
centuries more and while the details
have changed with retellings over the
years the story behind them goes like
this back in the early 13th century King
John the King John from the tales of
Robin Hood wanted to travel through this
town the locals were worried because if
the King traveled on a road it would
become a public highway and I didn't
want that
or in other retellings the king wants to
build a hunting lodge somewhere nearby
and the locals would have to pay for it
so whenever royal messengers arrived in
Gautam and they found the local was
doing something ridiculous they tried to
capture a cuckoo by building a circular
hedge around it and when the bird flew
away decided they just hadn't built the
hedge high enough they tried to kill him
eel by drowning it back then madness was
thought to be contagious
if the king was to visit this town but
who knows he might catch whatever they
had the king stayed away and the locals
won so the full legend tells the tale of
a wily group of people who helped witted
the king but who also became known as a
village of fools in the process they
were both the wise men of Gautam and the
Mad Men of Gautam centuries later in the
early 1800s there was an American writer
called Washington Irving he's best known
now for writing The Legend of Sleepy
Hollow but among many other things he
was a satirist and in one of his early
works he refers to New York City as
Gautam
now I tracked down that bit of writing I
can't understand it
I don't any other context I I don't if
he's calling the citizens of New York
dim or clever or both but the nickname
he gave New York stuck around in the
public consciousness and it was written
down so at some point Gautam became
more than a century after that one comic
book writer bill finger was looking for
a name for Batman's fictional town he
flipped through the New York City
phonebook spotted Gotham jewellers and
thought that's perfect so now we have
Gotham City if one link in that chain
had broken through 13th century legend
to 16th century insult book to 19th
century writer to 20th century phone
book flip if one of those small events
hadn't happened Batman would live
somewhere else